So, bubble wrap actually was never intended to be packaging material.
That's right; it was meant to be wallpaper.
Fun facts!
My name is Bradley Hart, and I'm known for making bubble wrap art.
I first select the perfect image,...
...load it into my computer software that I created, which allows me to zoom in and out,...
...colorizing the various bubbles one by one.
I then inject anywhere from three to 500 bubbles an hour.
My work allows me to explore the topics of plasticity of our world that we live in,...
...and to make the statements I want to.
My pieces range anywhere from 10,000 to 120,000 dollars.
My work plays with that cultural trope on whether or not you're allowed to touch art or not...
...because everybody just feels that need to want to zoom in and touch it.
My bubbles are not poppable.
They're filled with paint, and the paint is dry.